hello guys it's terrorists own here and
welcome to my first commentary video and
to started off I would a quick video for
you guys today
gran / community up the star was called
Jedi amino the app is available on iOS
and Android free to download with no ads
to make sure to check it out I
personally have the app on Android Sol's
amino is the largest mobile social
network for Star Wars fans you can build
a profile showing a passion for Star
Wars discuss your favorite movies
characters shows toys games and much
more you can gain a massive following by
sharing your thoughts finds interations
discover Star Wars fair not photos right
in close play and more chat about what
common movies like Star is a and other
scholars are later sir
also in Jedi amino you can create polls
and discussions share the bottle fans
show off your fan creations share
discuss and debate Star Wars furries in
the former section discover of the Star
Wars fans nearby in around the world who
share your passion ask and answer
questions under fly in search phone
expert answers on everything Star Wars
I'm gonna use the app to post Dauntless
facts post about style is in general and
have open discussion review fans the
simplest way to find this app is a
search for Jedi amino in the app store I
would recommend you guys go and follow
me to the easiest way to do that is to
search for Terra stone if you want to
make any suggestions for my channel feel
free to post it to me you Jedi Armenians
so that's pretty much it for this video
so thank you so much for watching
may the force be with you